bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver
l'actualité ce soir c'est la décision
française d'accueillir le navire Ocean
Vikings en France les 234 migrants à
bord de ce navire-humanitaire vont
accoster demain matin dans le port de
Toulon port militaire décision à titre
exceptionnel à insisté Gérald Darmanin
droite et extrême droite sont vent
debout crise diplomatique entre Paris et
Rome le tout à quelques semaines du
débat parlementaire sur le projet de loi
immigration n'en parle dans un instant
dans notre grand débat avec nos invités
sur ce plateau professions avocat c'est
une série exceptionnelle une collection
que vous propose LCP ce dimanche 6
grands entretien de ténor et de tenorah
du barreau questionné par l'excellente
daphnérolier il se confie sur leur
métier si particulier l'instinct de la
Défense le rôle du secret le rapport à
la vérité mettre Hervé Themime et l'une
des plus grandes voix du barreau l'un de
ces 6 avocats dans cette série il sera
avec nous pour en parler dans la
deuxième partie enfin trois affranchis
le soir trois parties pris le regard sur
l'Europe de Richard Berly les activistes
du climat à l'assaut des villes la
question du philosophe Pierre-Henri
tavoyau la désobéissance civile est-elle
un droit et puis venu perçoit elle va
mon Agava nous raconte pourquoi les
commissions d'enquête sont des objets
ultra politiques voilà pour le menu de
ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est donc la première fois que la
France accueille un bateau de migrants
au nom de l'urgence humanitaire les 234
migrants à bord de l'océan Viking
débarqueront demain matin dans le port
militaire de Toulon décision
exceptionnelle pleine le gouvernement
aussitôt pilonné par la droite et par le
rassemblement national bonsoir Mathieu
Lefebvre et merci d'être là vous êtes
député renaissance du Val-de-Marne et
ancien conseiller ministériel du cabinet
au cabinet de Gérald Darmanin au
ministère de l'Intérieur j'imagine que
vous connaissez bien le dossier bonsoir
Daniel obono ravi de vous accueillir
député la France insoumise de Paris
bonsoir Guilhem Carayon vous présidez
les jeunes républicains et puis Pascal
Brice qui préside la face la Fédération
des acteurs de solidarité c'est l'ancien
patron de l'OFPRA l'office français pour
la protection des réfugiés et des
apatrides qui va nous rejoindre dans un
tout petit instant je salue également
Olivier tosseri depuis Rome qui nous
dira comment on réagit du côté de
l'Italie mais d'abord on a besoin de
revenir sur cette décision Gérald
Darmanin exceptionnel qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire et quelles sont les réactions
la nuit blackovski tout de suite si j'ai
bien compris
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam
Gérald Darmanin n'imaginait pas que
Georgia mélony allait lui tenir tête
regardez la semaine dernière encore vous
voyez ça me faisait aucun doute pour lui
l'Italie bien sûr allait accueillir le
chêne Viking comme quoi tout le monde
peut se tromper en l'occurrence il avait
sous-estimé la détermination la mélodie
comme l'appelle les Italiens à tenir ses
promesses électorales tout simplement
souvenez-vous pendant sa campagne voilà
ce que le design voulait un blocus naval
donc c'est carrément de repousser les
migrants vers les ports dont ils étaient
partis donc résultat maintenant qu'elle
est élu donc elle a quand même accueilli
trois bateaux humanitaires mais pour le
quatrième donc en l'occurrence le
chènevik elle a dit non c'est la France
donc qui va accueillir ce bateau
exactement donc c'est ce que Gérald
Darmanin du annoncer ce matin à la
sortie du Conseil des ministres et
forcément il était un petit peu
contrarié on l'écoute
face à cette situation
les autorités françaises ont pris la
décision à titre exceptionnel de pallier
au comportement inacceptable du
gouvernement italien et d'inviter le
navire à rejoindre le port militaire de
Toulon il devrait y arriver ce vendredi
11 novembre en début de matinée alors
bien sûr c'est pour la France une
occasion de se montrer à la hauteur de
la valeur qu'elle incarne car nul ne
l'ignore la France est un phare qui
élimine le monde oui enfin moi j'en suis
convaincu mais faut pas exclure non plus
qu'il y a un petit calcul politique
derrière tout ça parce que quand même
souvenez-vous l'Aquarius bah si
l'Aquarius
le président Macron à l'époque il avait
refusé d'accueillir il y avait un peu
plus de 140 migrants sur ce bateau que
les Espagnols avaient fini par
accueillir donc c'était il y a 4 ans à
l'époque le chef de la gauche était
Mélenchon et il n'avait pas raté le
président regardez il avait dit mais
c'est quand même une honte quand on est
français de voir qu'on est abandonne
c'est pas que Jean c'était ne m'appelez
plus jamais France donc là a priori il
suffira moins de critiques du côté de la
gauche on verra
pas ça dans un instant sauf que cette
fois-ci les critiques viennent du
rassemblement national et des
républicains
sur lesquels le RN et les filles sont
d'accord mais alors certainement pas sur
l'immigration là il y a vraiment pas
d'arrangement possible du coup à défaut
d'être salué du côté Mélenchon il s'est
faite du côté Le Pen donc le tweet de
Marine Le Pen qui n'a pas tardé vous
voyez elle en fait pas trop juste
qu'elle souligne c'est la première fois
qu'on accueille un bateau elle dénonce
sous l'acide
Eric Ciotti dans la foulée là non plus
on n'est pas surpris il en fait un peu
plus il fait une référence à l'AMPE et
12a pour montrer qu'il est sur la même
ligne que que Marine Le Pen bon
évidemment si on accueille un bateau le
risque c'est que ça soit la porte
ouverte à toutes les fenêtres on écoute
l'analyse de Jordan Bardella
je pense que Madame Meloni a raison de
faire preuve de fermeté elle a raison
parce que c'est ce pourquoi elle a été
élue parce que accueille un bateau ça
veut dire en accueillir 10 mais ça
envoie un message à mon avis qui est
dramatique et qui invite ces personnes à
tenter l'aventure dans la Méditerranée
et donc à risquer des morts donc le
ministre a quand même dit que c'était
exceptionnel a priorité il est pas prévu
dans un accueillir mais alors comment
interpréter cette année
oh mon dieu Myriam mais ce que vous êtes
cruel de dire ça mais c'est pas de sa
faute il pouvait pas savoir que les
Italiens allaient changer la vie je vous
rappelle que en juin dernier il a signé
c'était plutôt à son avantage un pacte
sur la migration en Europe il y avait
une vingtaine de pays qui s'était mis
d'accord notamment Mario draglion en
Italie pour dire ok l'Italie accueille
les migrants qui ont été secourus en mer
et en échange d'autres pays européens
prennent une part de ces migrants sauf
que ceux pourquoi
draguer avait dit oui hier et bien
aujourd'hui
Mélanie dit non exactement la France
réagit comment alors c'est jamais une
très bonne idée de ce fâcher avec Gérald
Darmanin ça tout le monde le sait donc
forcément la France est très remontée il
est tellement remonté d'armanin que
j'imagine qu'il a même Macron qui leur
remontent encore un peu plus derrière
donc on sait pas exactement quoi mais on
a promis des conséquences très fortes
sur notre relation avec les Italiens je
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer mais en
tout cas première mesure pas question
d'accepter donc les 3500 migrants que la
France avait promis elle aussi
d'accueillir au titre de la
relocalisation des migrants en écoute
Darmanin
3500 realisations de réfugiés étaient
prévus d'ici l'été 2023 il est évident
qu'à effet immédiat la France suspend
l'ensemble des relocalisations donc de
ces 3500 réfugiés au bénéfice de
l'Italie et appelle tous les autres
participants notamment l'Allemagne au
mécanisme européen de faire de même bon
ben voilà moi je vous donne plein de
pistes pour le débat après ça vous
débattre je peux pas tout faire non plus
merci merci pour votre regard quotidien
Stéphane Mathieu Lefebvre c'est vrai
qu'on peut s'étonner en 2018 c'est la
position inverse qui avait été tenue par
Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il faut y voir
un changement doctrine en matière
d'accueil des bateaux de sauvetage de
migrants quand ils arrivent dans nos
mers il y a aucun changement de doctrine
le droit international et maritime
continuera à s'appliquer à cette
décision elle ne crée pas de précédent
elle vise simplement à répondre à une
situation humanitaire qui était
absolument dramatique il y a des enfants
qui allaient peut-être mourir si nous
n'avions rien fait la France n'avait
plus le choix à partir du moment
de la France quand des hommes et des
femmes s'apprêtent à mourir si on les
laisse une heure de plus sur un bateau
c'est évidemment le secourir parce que
l'honneur de la France était-il
différent et la situation des traces
aussi qui a fait preuve une position un
peu plus responsable que l'Italie
aujourd'hui a accueilli ces migrants et
a permis de leur sauver la vie mais je
veux insister sur le fait qu'il s'agit
d'une décision exceptionnelle elle ne
crée en aucun cas un appel d'air et le
droit international aura toujours
vocation à s'appliquer comment géralder
que vous connaissez si bien n'a-t-il pas
pu imaginer que Georgia Meloni a peine
élu allait dire stop au moins à ce
bateau là d'abord parce qu'il y a un
bras de fer il y a des négociations
diplomatiques Gérald Darmanin et la
négocié heure par heure avec son
homologue italien j'imagine pour que
l'Italie assume la voix de la raison et
face en sorte d'accueillir 200 personnes
qui
menaçaient d'être de mourir en mer ces
personnes ils ont envoyé des SOS pendant
des semaines donc Gérald Darmanin il a
joué la voix diplomatique maintenant à
un moment donné quelqu'un veut pas
reprendre un bateau on peut pas le
reprendre de force je crois que c'est
l'honneur de la France que de le faire
mais on parle d'honneur de la France
mais de situations exceptionnelles c'est
pas toujours facile de de s'y retrouver
en fait quand on essaie de comprendre ce
qui se joue Daniel au Bono là les
insoumis sont constants on peut se
souvenir de votre collègue Martin ce
bilongo dans l'émission qui a quelques
jours qui posaient la question et qui
disait au gouvernement il faut
accueillir ce bateau est-ce que vous
saluez clairement et franchement cette
décision de la France ce soir du
gouvernement parce que Emmanuel ce qui
aurait dû se faire tout de suite je
rappelle et ça a été dit effectivement
c'est le droit international qui indique
que il faut sauver les personnes qui
sont en danger et il y avait une
situation de détresse absolue je
rappelle que depuis 2014 plus de 24000
personnes sont mortes dans la
Méditerranée c'est un énorme cimetière
aujourd'hui cette mère et donc c'est pas
une question d'exception ou de
marchandages politiciens il s'agit pas
de trimballer des gens d'un côté ou de
l'autre de la Méditerranée
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si on peut
même parler non non il s'agit pas
d'avoir des médailles il s'agit tout
simplement de respecter le droit
international de respecter nos principes
nos valeurs et de le faire de manière
sans avoir besoin qu'on s'allume moi je
suis nous sommes satisfaits et
satisfaite de ce choix mais on peut
regretter que la situation est livrée
aussi longtemps parce que ça a créé des
situations terribles de détresse
psychologique et de mise en danger et
puis au-delà même je pense que on a des
on va avoir des débats à l'Assemblée sur
le positionnement par rapport à la
politique migratoire mais là il ne
s'agissait pas de là de ça quand il
s'agit d'aller sauver l'urgence et je
crois que nous devons nous nous avions
proposé qu'on mette en place en France
quand l'Europe ne le peut pas et ça
c'est un problème au niveau européen
aussi et il faudra il faudra le traiter
qu'on mette en place nous qu'on se donne
les moyens d'aller sauver des gens parce
que par ailleurs ce que font des
associations comme Ocean victime comme
SOS Méditerranée ils le font parce que
les gouvernements ne le font pas ça
devrait être nos gouvernements qui se
chargent
aussi de faire en sorte que des gens
arrêtent de mourir il y a quelques jours
encore en mer et j'ai une vingtaine de
personnes sont mortes 30 sont disparus
et des corps commencent à remonter et
arriver sur les côtes de graisse c'est
inacceptable c'est insupportable autour
de toi c'est notre responsabilité
d'éviter ces nouveaux drames et je dis
bienvenue à Pascal Brice merci
infiniment d'être là vous connaissez
très bien ces dossiers on va voir si on
peut avoir un débat apaisé sur cette
question des migrants à chaque fois
qu'un bateau à cause d'ailleurs pas
seulement en France c'est irruptif
partout en Europe Guillaume caraillon il
y a un congrès des républicains en ce
moment Éric Ciotti et candidat vous le
soutenez quand on voit sa réaction le
gouvernement complice des passeurs vous
trouvez que c'est à la hauteur quand
même franchement de l'urgence
humanitaire de dire ça bien sûr bien sûr
vous avez parlé de le calcul politique
de la part du ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin la réalité c'est qu'il a
mené un bras de fer depuis le début de
la semaine qu'il a perdu avec Georgia
Meloni et c'était attendu parce que
Georgia Meloni elle a été élu il y a
quelques semaines sur un principe très
simple non à l'immigration légale où
illégale les Italiens ne veulent plus
des migrations légales et illégales et
donc dure jamais le nez d'arriver
la une de tous les tutos de presse
aujourd'hui moi je crois que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on a aujourd'hui
avec cette affaire là avec cette
décision de mise en intérieur
l'inauguration en réalité ça prépare la
crise migratoire à venir vous allez
avoir un symbole qui a envoyé à des
dizaines de milliers voire des centaines
de milliers de migrants qui vont venir
dans les prochaines années dans les
prochaines décennies parce que il y a un
appel d'air qui est créé ils sont
incités à venir ils se disent bon bah si
vous êtes secourus sur les côtes
méditerranéennes et bien vous allez pas
être
vous allez pas être adossé à votre port
d'attache en Tunisie par exemple comme
ça aurait pu être le cas il faut juste
préciser là parce que on peut parler
d'appel d'air mais là on va parler de la
situation
aujourd'hui 15 jours d'attente en mer
234 migrants à bord de ce bateau et
l'Italie qui refuse qu'est-ce que vous
auriez fait qu'est-ce que vous auriez
fait qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire alors
sur les côtes
tunisienne à quelques kilomètres de la
Tunisie pourquoi ces gens-là ces
migrants là n'ont pas été
à la côte
et la question n'est pas les laisser
mourir ces gens-là n'auraient pas du
tout ces gens-là mais à partir du moment
où ils sont là en pleine mer on peut
décider que effectivement je pense que
elle ne vous doit être certainement pas
vous inciter de plus en plus de migrants
à venir sur les côtés international il y
a la nouvelle donne italienne politique
et puis maintenant on entend à droite
oui au soin d'urgence pour les enfants
il y avait même des bébés sur ce bateau
mais non à l'accueil c'est votre
position aussi à droite c'est que vous
avez des ONG comme SOS Méditerranée qui
jouent avec les vie des gens et qui sont
complices aujourd'hui de passeurs qui
font commerce de vie humaine c'est un
esclavagisme moderne qui est en train de
se jouer là et on a des ONG qui sont
complices de ces passeurs là
on a besoin de votre éclairage c'est
vrai les chiffres quand on les regarde
sont terribles 1628 morts en
Méditerranée depuis de 2022
3300 en 2021 à chaque fois c'est le même
débat qu'est-ce qui a changé qu'est-ce
qui change dans ces débats et je pense
que Madame Meloni
a ce qu'elle cherche
exacerber
ces tensions qui existent dans les
sociétés européennes autour la question
des migrations c'est très bien ce
qu'elle fait
moi ce qui me consterne dans cette
situation moi je voudrais saluer ici
également français Vous saluez ce soir
la décision mais bien sûr c'est que ces
hommes ces femmes ces enfants ont enfin
puissent toucher terre on puisse
s'occuper d'elle et s'occuper d'eux et
donc je salue cette décision simplement
vous le rappeliez moi j'ai connu ces
situations il y a 4 ans mais
exactement les mêmes exactement les
mêmes
les mêmes états les mêmes personnes les
mêmes mécanismes les mêmes mots il y a 4
ans lorsque j'étais directeur de l'ofra
que je suis allé à la demande du
Président de la République accueillir
les personnes de l'Aquarius à Valence
puis ensuite à Malte puis ensuite en
Italie
exactement donc rien ne change donc si
c'est passé moi je vous le dis
franchement je ne comprends pas je dédie
à cette époque là que l'on n'est pas mis
à profit ces quatre années pendant
lesquelles nous avions un gouvernement
italien qui n'était pas d'un
gouvernement d'extrême droite pour
trouver une solution
alors justement et donc de ce
conformisme là qui est que oui on nous
dit qu'on va le remettre en œuvre Dublin
remettre en cause du Blin mais rien ne
se passe dans le détail parce qu'il y a
un accord qui a été passé avec les
italiens mais c'était Mario Draghi sous
présidente française qui n'a pas été
respectée par par Georgia Meloni bonsoir
Olivier toséri et merci d'avoir patienté
vous êtes correspondant entre autres des
échos à Rome déjà on a l'impression que
Georgia mélodie doit savourer sa
victoire Gérald Darmanin dénonce ce soir
une attitude inacceptable de l'Italie
comment réagit le gouvernement italien
et bien évidemment le gouvernement
italien présente ça comme ça première
victoire dans une épreuve de force et a
forti avec la France un pays qui est
souvent
dénoncé pour son atelier de arrogante et
défiante à l'égard de l'Italie le
ministre des Affaires étrangères
italiens avait d'ailleurs confirmé que
le tri des migrants ceux qui pouvaient
débarquer ou pas les marques en Italie
était une attitude qui servait à lancer
un signal pour forcer l'Europe à aider
davantage d'Italie et puis Matteo
Salvini évidemment exulte c'est très
bien la musique change et il est
immédiatement commenté c'est surtout la
réaction du ministre italien d'intérieur
qui est intéressant parce qu'il a fait
part de son incompréhension de sa totale
incompréhension face à la décision
française de mesures de rétention
annoncées par Gérald Darmanin selon lui
la France ne fait que répondre aux
appels continuels à la solidarité pour
ces migrants et il ne comprend pas
pourquoi et bien ce que l'Italie devrait
accepter le Congrès et bien les autres
ne sont pas disposés et bien
c'était il veut évidemment que ce
problème soit pris à bras le corps par
l'Europe
jameloni est au pouvoir les Italiens
eux-mêmes réagissent on attend
évidemment les premiers sondages mais il
lui font crédi d'avoir gagné ce bras de
fer
l'immigration n'est pas partie de des
problèmes prioritaires des Italiens
c'est l'inflation c'est l'explosion des
prix de l'énergie l'immigration ne
faisait plus partie des une des journaux
italiens ces derniers mois elle refait
évidemment
les titres des médias de la presse
italienne vous l'avez dit dans de la
mélodie bien-être élue elle jouit pour
l'instant d'une très importante code de
popularité de d'un certain état de grâce
et les deux tiers des Italiens sont
plutôt favorables à une ligne assez dure
et ferme à l'égard de l'immigration
est-ce qu'on peut parler de graves
crises entre Paris et Rome les premières
mesures de rétorsion la France rétablit
le contrôle aux frontières refusent
d'appliquer les accords de solidarité en
prenant en leur part si j'ose dire sur
les 3000 migrants arrivés en Italie
c'est grave ces tensions
c'est comme ça que c'est présenté par
l'ensemble des médias italiens de
manière unanime c'est la première crise
diplomatique que doit affronter Georgia
Meloni ce sont des tensions avec la
France qui ne n'était pas aussi élevé
depuis quelques années depuis
les très très forte tension en 2018 qui
était notamment provoqué par la gestion
de la crise migratoire et donc
effectivement pour l'italier pour les
médias italiens la relation entre les
deux pays est à son plus bas niveau
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS Olivier to
série depuis Rome Mathieu Lefebvre c'est
jusqu'où va aller cette cette crise avec
l'Italie vous avez entendu les Italiens
ils disent on accueille 90 000 migrants
seulement cette année donc 234 en France
ce discours là beaucoup de gens peuvent
l'entendre qu'est-ce que vous répondez
il faut il faut aller jusqu'où dans la
pression sur l'Italie d'abord pas plus
que l'Italie la France n'a vocation elle
non plus accueillir l'ensemble des
bateaux de migrants et toute la misère
du monde pour reprendre l'expression
bien connue et simplement que les
Italiens qui sont directement le premier
pays d'arrivée quand ils viennent comme
c'est le cas social Vikings de Libye
puisse dire stop et on voit bien les
mots les monter des populismes à cause
de ça d'abord il y a ce mécanisme
européen qui permet précisément de
partager le fardeau et faire en sorte
que quand on est des pays qui ont
notamment un littoral très très élevé et
qui accueille beaucoup de migrants de
les partager avec l'ensemble des pays
européens ça c'est un mécanisme que
ça marche ça fonctionne
2022 qui a été lancé en juin 2022
il faut évidemment pouvoir répartir ce
fardeau mais on peut pas quand on est un
pays européen dire je reçois tous les
financements de l'Europe et je m'extrais
des règles quand elle me plaisent pas ça
ce n'est pas possible c'est la raison
pour laquelle le ministre a eu raison
d'être très très ferme en rappelant que
ce mécanisme de relocalisation les
migrants que les Français devaient
reprendre l'an prochain ils ne les
reprendra Pascal pris je vous donne la
parole dans un pour l'instant mais
puisqu'on arrive sur ce mécanisme
européen et cet accord signé notamment
entre l'Allemagne l'Italie et la France
efficace ou non que prévoit-il
précisément on voit cela avec Stéphanie
des pierres
un bateau qui est au milieu de la
Méditerranée car aucun pays européen ne
l'autorisation
de migrants sauvés de la noyade par une
ONG alors que l'oen Viking est dans leur
eau Malte l'Italie refuse d'ouvrir leurs
ports pour qu'ils débarque ses passagers
c'est pourtant la règle endroit maritime
quatre ans après l'Aquarius le scénario
se répète encore et encore
pourtant l'Union européenne croyait
avoir trouvé une solution en juin elle a
créé un mécanisme volontaire de
solidarité les pays méditerranéens
acceptent le débarquement des migrants
en échange les autres États membres en
accueillent une partie sur leur
territoire sinon il verse une aide
financière ou matériel au pays haute la
France par exemple s'est engagée à
accueillir 3000 migrants par an venus de
Grèce d'Italie ou de Malte
sauf que ce mécanisme n'a rien de
contraignant aucune obligation donc pour
Rome de recevoir ces clandestins aucune
obligation non plus pour les autres pays
européens des berger les nouveaux
arrivants l'Italie comme la Grèce
dénonce régulièrement le manque
d'empressement de leur voisin ce
mécanisme de solidarité était temporaire
pour un an mais vu les tensions
diplomatiques actuelles il est déjà
menacé
voilà ce mécanisme au fond explose en
vol c'était peut-être la première
occasion de l'appliquer et Georgia
mélodie ne l'applique pas parce qu'il
n'est pas contraignant c'est ça le
problème principal c'est surtout qu'on
l'a adopté en juin en juin nous savions
déjà tous hélas que l'extrême droite à
l'épreuvement gagnant d'Italie donc
c'est en 2018 que à la demande du
Président de la République nous avons
commencé à mettre en place ce type de
dispositif c'est 4 ans après que l'on au
mois de juin on signe cet accord qui en
réalité n'est pas mis en oeuvre or elle
est là la solution me semble-t-il la
solution est là la solution est que
lorsque les personnes arrivent dans les
ports européens soient accueillies dans
de bonnes conditions que l'on statue sur
leur situation et que lorsqu'elle relève
du droit au séjour elle puisse être
accueillie un peu partout en Europe il
est là un objectif et moi je le savais
essayer d'expliquer aujourd'hui entre
France et Allemagne Italie ça fait
quatre ans que l'on sait que c'est ce
dispositif là qui veut fonctionner moi
je veux saluer Clément Beaune qui mise à
faire européenne lui c'est beaucoup
battu pour cela n'a pas été toujours
entendu on l'a signé en donc il n'a pas
été mis en oeuvre cet accord on savait
très bien que on attend quoi que
l'extrême droite revienne en Italie au
pouvoir c'est fait est-ce qu'on peut
s'étonner
est-ce que l'on peut s'étonner que
Madame mélonie mène une politique qui
est celle de l'extrême droite
et qui est de considérer que elle a une
raison d'être dans la vie c'est de
mettre les étrangers dehors je vois pas
trop où est la surprise alors je veux
bien que pendant trois semaines y
compris la Commission européenne est
fait comme si tout ça a été relativement
normal parce qu'on donnait des mesdames
Meloni semblaient très pro-européenne et
tout allait bien mais voilà on revient à
ce qui était devant nous parce qu'on n'a
pas fait le nécessaire depuis 4 ans
parce qu'on laisse s'installer dans les
sociétés européennes le poison de la
xénophobie à force de laisser des choses
à volo
et on se retrouve à nouveau devant des
chantages de cette nature
d'avoir trop tardé ce sont les
responsables européens vous citiez
Clément bonne qui a travaillé mais
c'était juste avant l'élection
de travailler dans tout cela avec mes
équipes y compris pour aller à Valence à
pozzalo etc accueillir les bateaux pour
avoir une toute petite opinion de cela
ce que je constate c'est qu'à force de
conformisme
parce qu'on a laissé les ministères
d'intérieur français allemand et
quelques autres gérés ou ne pas gérer
que enfin on avait un gouvernement
italien qui était sans l'extrême droite
en 2018 on pouvait enfin mettre les
choses sur la table à l'Italie à la
Grèce à l'Espagne d'assumer leur
responsabilité quand les gens arrivent
ils sont pris en charge comme il le faut
l'Union européenne finance et être pour
que ça se passe bien on répartit
l'accueil rien de tout ça était fait on
a attendu juin 2020 pour enfin faire un
accord à quelques-uns et évidemment on
se retrouve devant le mur à nouveau
l'extrême droite en Italie vous ne citer
pas directement Emmanuel Macron j'ai
bien compris mais il y a quand même un
petit problème de responsabilité vous
êtes d'accord avec ça en tout cas de
responsabilité en Europe oui clairement
mais je voudrais d'abord objecter une
partie des choses qui ont été dites ni
la France ni l'Europe n'accueille toute
la misère du monde la misère du monde
elle est accueillie dans les pays
limitrophes dans le grand sud la grande
majorité des migrants et des migrantes
première chose deuxième chose les
traversées les les arrivées ont diminué
depuis 2015 qui était le pic où il y
avait eu ce type de d'arrivée pour la
guerre en Syrie extraite on connaît on
connaît ces causes donc on n'est pas là
face à une invasion comme l'extrême
droite aime elle racontait et on n'est
pas là non plus dans On n'est pas là en
plus on n'est pas là voilà ou un rôle de
symbole de toute une politique vous le
savez bien et ils ont des conséquences
électorales très importantes c'est pour
ça juste terminer mon deuxième point on
sait comment faire on a eu un exemple il
y a quelques mois et c'était et c'était
juste et il fallait le faire quand on a
pu accueillir les réfugiés Ukrainiens on
sait que on peut mettre en place des
dispositifs qui marchent c'est pas
simple il faut travailler à ça mais on a
vu que c'était possible donc d'accord de
juin dernier vous étiez derrière pour
dire oui il faut y aller on est d'accord
on soutien effectivement au niveau
français comme européen donc on sait que
matériellement organisationnellement
c'est possible mais là où vous là où
vous touchez du doigt c'est que c'est un
symbole politique voire politicien c'est
utiliser c'est pas une question de
moyens de possibilités c'est une
question de volonté politique et bien
sûr c'est utilisé ça utilisait depuis 30
40 ans pour agiter des peurs pour
stigmatiser quand on l'a dit en Italie
les gens ce qui les inquiète ce n'est
pas une invasion c'est le quotidien
c'est l'inflation et c'est utilisé de
manière politique de manière assez
Mathieu lui-même et c'est là où il est
le problème c'est pourquoi Toulon
pourquoi un port militaire qu'est-ce que
ça change il y avait une gêne à ce que
ces migrants n'arrivent dans un port
traditionnel classique il faut que ces
migrants et puissent aussi faire des
demandes spécifiques de type de séjour
des demandes d'asile pour qu'ils
puissent ou non avoir vocation à être
éloigné ou avoir droit au séjour en
France il y a des formalités sanitaires
médicales j'imagine plus adapté je pense
que le port de Toulon est plus adapté si
vous voyez juste de répondre à Madame au
bonhomme vous dites la peur c'est
l'inflation il y a pas de problème avec
l'immigration je suis désolé de vous le
dire Madame bobonneau en un sujet de
flux migratoire et des gens sont dans
une situation parfois d'angoisse par par
rapport à l'immigration mais moi je
crois que entre le grand remplacement la
submersion migratoire le fait de penser
l'autre comme étant un délinquant en
puissance et l'accueille inconditionnel
de tous les étrangers il y a une
troisième voie objective des passionnés
qui consiste à accueillir les étrangers
qui souhaitent s'intégrer en France et à
éloigner ceux qui ne souhaitent pas
s'intégrer en France voilà donc là vous
voilà vous déjà vous dessinez le projet
de loi immigration qui va arriver à
partir de à partir de janvier Guilhem
Carayon moi je crois en même temps est
en train d'être tenté en matière
d'immigration peut-être à travers cette
décision peut-être avec le texte qui
arrive oui il y a de la volonté dans les
mots lutter contre l'immigration
illégale mais il y a l'impuissance dans
les actes la vérité c'est que le dernier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron c'est 2
millions d’étrangers qui sont arrivés de
manière légale où illégale c'est un
record c'est un record donc la crise
migratoire elle est en train de elle est
en train d'arriver et elle va être
inédite elle va être d'une ampleur qui
est inimaginable avec les référence avec
le réchauffement climatique avec
l'extrême pauvreté qui a dans les pays
africains qui sont la grande majorité
des pays d'où viennent ces immigrés donc
la solution pour les républicains
il faut pas taxer de xénophobie ceux qui
veulent qu'on reprenne le contrôle de
notre politique migratoire quand vous
parlez de des quelques centaines de
personnes qui vont arriver en France qui
sont des réfugiés de l'Océane Viking la
réalité c'est que pour la plupart elles
ne vont pas obtenir le titre de séjour
et le problème qui se pose après ça va
être comment on les explose du
territoire national parce qu'elles ont
plus rien à faire chez nous et le
problème c'est qu'on est à 10% de qtf
qui sont exécutés depuis le début du
décalage
qui permettra d'aller plus vite si ça
peut permettre d'augmenter le taux
d'exécution des hôpitaux mais on est à
10% réduire les délais et la possibilité
de recours sur ces décisions mais c'est
pour ça que je voudrais
sur le projet de loi immigration
le choix d'appuyer et de dérouler le
tapis rouge
pas moi j'ai été chef de fil sur ce
débat en 2018 on a il y avait déjà eu un
texte on s'y est opposé comme s'ils sont
opposés toutes les organisations de
défense des droits humains parce que ce
n'était pas une réponse réelle on a vu
que c'était possible d'accord
attendez s'il vous plaît là on est en
train d'aller sur l'immigration s'il
vous plaît je voudrais madame
danger et là vous commencez à dérouler
typiquement immigration délinquant vous
voyez vous voyez vraiment l'indécence le
cynisme
à Paris qui sont des étrangers je vous
promets qu'on va terminer ce débat avec
le projet de loi immigration qui n'a
strictement rien à voir avec la question
des réfugiés humanitaires et de ce
bateau c'est quand même deux choses
extrêmement différentes moi déjà je
voudrais comprendre sur la question de
l'asile Dublin on entend ce mot Dublin 1
2 3 4 c'est très compliqué c'est
toujours en place c'est-à-dire que c'est
dans le pays d'arriver qu'on doit faire
la demande d'asile y compris après le
système de solidarité c'est-à-dire même
si ces migrants sont je mets des
guillemets relocalisés pour utiliser le
terme européen c'est comme ça toujours
que ça se passe c'est effectivement une
réalité un signal politique qui est
donné au pays d'arriver direct l'Italie
au sud de l'Europe sur lequel c'est à
eux de se débrouiller
ça c'est efficace de garder la demande
d'asile dans le pays d'arrivée pas tant
et ça fabrique de l'extrême droite
partout expliquez-nous ça tout
simplement parce que cette un système
qui ne marche pas
les Italiens voient bien qu'en réalité
ça ne fonctionne pas nous-mêmes nous
voyons que ça ne fonctionne pas parce
que les Italiens disent qu'ils
accueillent beaucoup de monde
les migrants doivent revenir faire
valider ou invalider leur demande à
vivre dans le pays ne fonctionne pas
donc ça alimente le désordre moi je vais
vous dire tromper ma sensation c'est que
les Français ni les Italiens ne se
réveillent tous les matins en se disant
il y a un problème d'immigration dans le
pays par contre je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose qui travaille la société
française
italienne américaine vous avez de la
fragilisation sociale fragilisation
culturelle et donc dans ces moments là
la question de la place des étrangers
devient incandescente on a déjà connu
donc il faut l'affronter me semble-t-il
de cette manière et bien il faut
effectivement avoir une capacité à avoir
un contrôle de l'immigration une
immigration un accueil qui soit
organisée et maîtrisée un accueil
d'abord c'est pour ça que je conseille
la question de la demande d'asile et qui
fait partie de cela parce que la
migration c'est à la fois l'asile ce
sont des situations humanitaires c'est
le travail et c'est pour ça que je dis
moi au nom de notre fédération
d'associations j'espère que Monsieur
Darmanin va aller au bout de la logique
dont il nous parle maintenant qui moi
parait bienvenue et bien c'est de dire
que désormais là où on avait des besoins
c'est-à-dire si j'ai bien compris si
j'ai bien entendu le ministre désormais
on considère que l'immense majorité des
étrangers dans ce pays qu'ont beaucoup
sont dans la précarité dans nos
associations et bien on vocation avoir
accès à un séjour pour travailler et
qu'en revanche celles et ceux qui posent
de vrais problèmes doivent être ne pas
avoir une de ces jours donc moi je
souhaite qu'on aille au bout de cette
logique qui est une logique de maîtrise
d'accueil et de maîtrise là encore au
niveau européen si nous avions ce
dispositif d'accueil à l'arrivée de
répartition et bien nous serions dans
des situations d'éviterait à la fois des
atteintes à la dignité des personnes 15
jours en mer
et des situations qui provoquent du
désordre social et dans la tête des gens
avec les méchants en tout cas moi c'est
la phrase un peu binaire si je peux me
permettre de permanence évidemment je
pense sera plus fin techniquement que
que cela mais je crois monsieur aussi
que pour bien intégrer il faut aussi
mieux maîtriser les flux migratoires et
il faut que nous ayons la capacité à
pouvoir renvoyer plus rapidement celles
et ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à rester
sur le territoire national en revanche
moi je ne crois pas que même sur
l'immigration de travail nous ayons
besoin de faire appel à de la main
d'oeuvre étrangère nous avons d'ores et
déjà des gens qui sont parfois dans des
exploités dans des restaurants dans des
hôtels et qui travaillent extrêmement
durs la régularisation d'étrangers qui
ont un travail aujourd'hui
non il a été il a parlé il a parlé d'un
titre de séjour c'est-à-dire le ministre
régularisation
en fait justement la solution
qui sont temporaires madame au Bono et à
l'issue de cette période temporelle et
par ailleurs
de Gérald Darmanin et du macronisme de
manière générale c'est-à-dire qu'on vous
dit on va contrôler d'une manière plus
efficace la politique migratoire et en
même temps on va créer une nouvelle
filière d'immigration à travers la
régularisation des clandestins qui
travaillent c'est pas c'est pas en
créant une nouvelle filière qu'on va
mieux maîtriser nos politiques
migratoire je crois pas ça n'est pas une
régularisation
écoutez rendez-vous je vous le mot de la
fin vous avez vraiment 10 secondes
maximum
moi je peux ma boulangerie chez moi
Malakoff elle me dit sans arrêt qu'elle
a besoin de gens pour bosser c'est
partout partout pareil vous voyez des
commerçants les artisans des patrons ils
ont besoin de personne pour travailler
et dans les structures des associations
il y a des gens qui ne demandent qu'à ça
que ça donc voilà qu'on le fasse dans
les là où on a besoin
plateau parce que les consultations vont
commencer au ministère de l'Intérieur et
puis il y a ce texte qui arrive donc
après le congrès tiens après le congrès
des républicains début janvier à
l'Assemblée nationale merci merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur le plateau LCP
on va parler à présent de cette
collection exceptionnelle que vous
proposez LCP cette semaine et ce
week-end professions avocat si grands
entretiens de ténor et tenorah du
barreau mené par la toujours très fine
Daphné Rollier l'instinct de la Défense
le rôle du secret l'art de plaider le
rapport à la vérité confidence sur un
métier très particulier mettre Hervé
thémime et l'une des grandes voix de
cette très belle collection parle avec
lui juste après l'invitation de Marco
poli
si on vous invite RVT mime c'est parce
que vous plaidez une certaine idée de la
justice vous l'avez raconté à Daphné
Roulier dans ses grands entretiens vous
mais aussi Serge Klarsfeld Henri Leclerc
Marie dosée Thierry Moser ou encore
Julia Minkowski les ténors du barreau je
me suis dit bon si tu me profession qui
me convient parce que je ne sais rien
faire donc je peux être avocat lorsque
je vois quelqu'un qui est qui est
accablé j'ai envie de le défendre Hervé
tes mimes vous êtes d'après vanity faire
le plus puissant avocat de France
relaxator c'est votre surnom vous
détestez perdre près de 45 ans de
métiers et une ribambelle de clients
célèbres Bernard Tapie Gérard Depardieu
Roman Polanski pour ne citer que de vous
nous retenons aussi ce livre paru en
2020 véritable déclaration d'amour à
votre profession vous vous inquiétez de
puissance du tribunal médiatique et des
attaques contre le secret professionnel
et le secret donc il est fait pour
protéger la justice c'est vrai ça paraît
curieux ça paraît être grandiloquant il
est frais pour protéger l'intérêt
supérieur de la justice parce que il est
le socle de la défense vous êtes une
voix RVT mime mais une voix claire non
virulente dans vos plaidoiries de quoi
plaire à votre associé Julia Minkowski
elle vous considère comme son mentor à
l'origine du club des femmes pénalistes
elle défend une autre façon de plaider
le prétoire ce lieu symbolique d'une
salle d'audience autrefois réservée aux
hommes il y a un côté très viriliste
dans l'image d'Épinal de l'avocat
pénaliste oui c'est vrai ça doit être un
homme plutôt de fortes corpulence avec
une grosse voix comme si celui qui
parlait le plus fort avait forcément
raison mais les temps ont changé les
temps ont changé la justice évolue mais
encore faut-il défendre ses fondations
Marie-José fait l'éloge de la
prescription plus que l'oubli judiciaire
c'est pour elle un instrument de lutte
contre l'arbitraire un discours peu
audible à contre-courant même mais parce
qu'on confond justice et vengeance il ne
faut pas qu'on puisse croire que parce
que celui que vous a fait souffrir
souffrira on souffrira moins c'est pas
vrai alors RVT mime la justice est-elle
malade sombrons-nous dans le populisme
pénal l'air des citoyens justiciers qui
défilent
à vous la parole
bonsoir maître Temime Hervé Timmy merci
infiniment d'être là à la défense dans
la peau c'est le titre de cette très
belle collection menée par l'excellente
Daphné Roulier et titre d'ailleurs
emprunté Alain de vos livres alors ce
métier d'avocat vous l'adorez vous le
chérissez vous l'avez au tripes chevillé
au corps c'est aussi une affaire de
transmission ce métier-là il faut
l'expliquer il faut le faire partager
ce n'est qu'une affaire de transmission
je sais que l'un des plus beaux
compliments que j'ai reçu dans ma vie
c'était alors que j'étais jeune avocat
un avocat immense qui vient de
disparaître Jean-Louis Pelletier qui m'a
envoyé un de ses livres en mode
dédicaçant en dédication à Hervé avocat
de lignée et j'ai compris j'avais
compris avant mais j'ai compris
qu'effectivement c'était une lignée et
la transmission de ce métier c'est
quelque chose de fondamental et qui ne
cesse d'exister on est un métier alors
il y a par exemple à Paris il y a plus
vraiment de lieux pour se rencontré mais
vous pouvez pas savoir à quel point les
plus anciens dont je fais maintenant
malheureusement partie ne cesse de
transmettre aux plus jeunes des années
des souvenirs
dans cette entretien on va pas toutes
les données parce que sinon voilà il
faut découvrir il y a 6 avocats très
différents de femmes dont l'une et Julia
micovski on l'a vu c'est votre associé
quatre hommes plusieurs générations et
il y a une figure totémique une
référence d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant parce que vous en parlez et
puis par exemple Marie d'oser en parle
c'est Henri Leclerc mettre le Clair
d'ailleurs elle raconte qu'elle est
devenue avocate après avoir entendu
l'une de ces plaidoiries pourquoi lui
pourquoi il a une place à part parmi les
grands pénalistes les ténors de la
défense alors d'abord parce que mais
c'est pas sa première qualité il a une
carrière d'une longévité exceptionnelle
Henri Leclerc a commencé à être avocat
très jeune comme on était souvent à
cette époque et il vient seulement de
s'arrêter il a été avocat pendant plus
de 65 ans et c'est un avocat qui est un
avocat exceptionnel dans sa qualité dans
son intégrité dans son humilité dans son
humanité et qui est aussi un homme
exceptionnel je dois dire que pour moi
Henri Leclerc est l'un des plus grands
français vivants et il est selon moi je
le connais bien quand je le connais bien
je n'ai pas travaillé pour lui je suis
pas son meilleur ami j'ai beaucoup
d'amitié d'affection pour lui j'espère
qu'il en a un peu pour moi et je ne dis
pas ça par complaisance à son égard
c'est une référence morale comme il y en
a peu je connais personnellement j'ai pu
l'éprouver éprouver il y a une anecdote
qu'on va pas raconter parce qu'elle est
extraordinaire vous l'avez raconté dans
Secret Défense chez Gallimard vous
Laurent raconter c'est un délice de vous
entendre parler si parce que c'est la
question du secret professionnel de
l'avocat vous êtes un homme qui aimait
viscéralement le secret vous aimez les
choses qui doivent rester cachées
presque au-delà même de votre profession
on va laisser les téléspectateurs
découvrir ce que c'est d'ailleurs vous
vous allez voir Henri Leclerc pour lui
demander conseil mais on garde le secret
si j'ose dire pour cette émission mais
vous dites adaphné rouliez le secret ne
protège pas l'avocat ou bien son client
il protège la justice expliquer nous ça
contrairement à ce que parfois on
imagine le secret prochaine n'est pas un
privilège de l'avocat au contraire pour
l'avocat c'est une obligation l'avocat
est tenu au secret l'avocat doit le
respecter s'il ne le respecte pas il le
viole et il commet une infraction le
faisant le secret professionnel à la
France et c'est un système
extraordinaire que le système judiciaire
français qu'on critique sans cesse c'est
un système formidable c'est un système
dans lequel le secret ne protège pas
davantage le client la personne que
l'avocat conseille ou défend puisque
contrairement à ce qui se passe partout
ailleurs ou presque par tout ailleurs le
client ne peut pas délier l'avocat du
secret professionnel je ne peux pas être
dédié par vous si je suis votre avocat
du secret que je dis bien donc le secret
professionnel c'est une règle qui est
faite parce que elle protège le bon
fonctionnement de la justice c'est le
pilier de la défense pénale et la
justice c'est tout bête de le dire mais
c'est vrai c'est l'équilibre c'est la
balance c'est donc l'équilibre entre la
défense et l'accusation pour qu'il y ait
une justice juste il faut qu'il y a une
justice équilibrée et donc une défense
forte et qu'on protège ce pilier de la
défense quel secret professionnel une
défense forte pour vous là aussi c'est
une évidence avocat de la défense d'où
vous vient cet instinct de la défense
écoutez il me vient d'abord vous savez
une vocation née curieusement parce que
chez moi c'est une vocation véritable
absolument pas reconstruite qui est né
très jeune vers 12-13 ans mais qui n'est
pas lié ni à un entourage familial ni à
une connaissance particulière d'avocat
ni à la connaissance des procès écoutez
je crois que c'est lié on peut devenir
on peut faire bien d'autres choses quand
on est comme ça c'est lié à à une très
très vive sensibilité à l'injustice qui
est probablement niche très tôt chez moi
probablement aussi à la mythologie des
avocats douleurs personnelles
je ne connais pas d'avocat
que j'admire et j'en admire beaucoup
qui n'est pas éprouvé une forte douleur
dans son existence ou qu'il soit pas
d'une sensibilité particulière à la
douleur des uns et des autres vous me
direz il y a d'abord la douleur des
victimes bien sûr bien sûr mais et c'est
vrai que la fonction de l'avocat c'est
d'abord de défendre un homme ou une
femme accusée alors pour un avocat de la
défense la vérité la recherche de la
vérité
elle n'est pas primordiale elle est
secondaire
par rapport au respect du droit c'est
pas qu'elle n'est pas primordiale ou
secondaire c'est que le rôle de l'avocat
n'est pas de la recherche généralement
quand on pose cette question les avocats
pénalistes répondent et je les comprends
c'est pas mon problème la vérité oui
c'est pas un problème mais c'est un
problème si vous pensez que les avocats
sont absolument indifférents la vérité
mais l'avocat n'est pas là pour
rechercher la vérité il n'est pas là non
plus pour juger son client l'avocat
n'est pas là pour défendre
l'indéfendable quand je dis indéfendable
ça n'est pas la aucune cause enfin aucun
fait n'est un défendable à lui seul tout
tout fait commis par un homme ou une
femme est commis par quelqu'un qui fait
partie de notre humanité en revanche on
peut pas on peut pas soutenir quand on
est avocat qui fait jour quand il fait
nuit on peut pas mentir c'est pas du
tout comme ça en revanche et c'est tout
le le paradoxe de l'avocat est aussi le
le phénomène absolument passionnant de
la rhétorique de l'avocat ça consiste à
ne pas rechercher la vérité mais à ne
jamais mentir en défendant celui ou
celle qu'on défend encore trop peu de
femmes parmi alors comment on les
appelle les Sopranos du barreau les
ténora du baron est-ce que quand on est
pané c'est qu'il y a déjà un problème
les ténors eux on les voit et on les
entend
ça c'est un vaste sujet je suis heureux
que Julia Minkowski qui est mon associé
qui qui a commencé au barreau avec moi
et que j'ai la chance d'avoir encore à
mes côtés j'espère pour toujours je lui
ai miskowski défendent cette cause qui
est tout à fait juste moi franchement je
l'avais anticipé ce mouvement qui
consiste tout à fait logiquement à
rétablir un déséquilibre qui était
absolu il faut pas sombrer non plus dans
le manichéisme avocate
avec des grands dossiers qui arrivent à
voilà à se faire respecter
en revanche je pense que la défense n'a
pas de genre un avocat ou une avocate
n'est pas bon parce qu'il est un homme
ou une femme c'est pas vrai et même je
j'entendais la façon de le pardon
l'interview de Julia j'ai vu un très bon
documentaire qu'elle a fait il y a
parfois une forme de vanité c'est pas
vrai les effets de manche ne sont pas la
pandage des hommes on peut être ridicule
en étant une femme avocate et pour être
un grand avocat de la défense
certainement pas mais ça peut ne pas
décerner
vous avez un confrère Thierry Moser qui
parle de l'affaire de sa vie l'affaire
Grégory qui défend les époux les époux
Villemin il y a une affaire vous qui
restera plus que les autres
parce que elle a marqué aussi ma
jeunesse c'est une affaire que j'ai
plaidé il y a maintenant 40 ans et que
j'ai connu dans la première année de
barreau devant l'inscription au barreau
donc quand j'avais 21 ans c'est une
affaire où j'ai eu à défendre un jeune
homme
qui était accusé d'avoir tué son père
qui s'accusait de ses faits qui était
accusé par sa mère mais qui a été selon
moi j'en suis absolument convaincu
totalement innocent il était et j'ai
réussi alors qu'il s'accusait au procès
qui était accusé par sa mère j'ai réussi
j'ai contribué à faire en sorte qu'il
soit acquitté malgré lui et que sa mère
le soit aussi pour des raisons lié à son
état mental donc le rapport que j'ai eu
avec la vérité et le rapport strictement
inverse que celui qu'on connaît
généralement moi j'ai su qu'on dit
comment pouvez-vous défendre quelqu'un
vous savez que les coupables comment
pouvez-vous défendre quelqu'un vous
savez qu'il est innocent en disant qu'il
est coupable j'ai pas pu la condamnation
d'un homme même qui le voulait alors
qu'il était innocent mais était
insupportable et j'ai eu la chance de de
pouvoir l'éviter
les Français sont presque au bord du
divorce quand on regarde la manière dont
il la regarde quel mot vous mettriez sur
sur son état on entendait Marie doser
vraiment faire
critiquer une forme de populisme pénal
cette volonté de vengeance qu'on a vu
dans certaines affaires il y a il y a il
y a un état inquiétant de la justice il
y a un manque de confiance dans la
justice il y a un peu plus
judiciaire il y a surtout un peu plus
médiatique par rapport aux affaires
judiciaires mais je vais vous dire une
chose puisqu'il faut répondre en très
peu de temps moi ce qui me paraît plus
important c'est de ne pas crier à eau
sur le modèle il faut défendre les juges
bien sûr qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont
plus que critiques après il faut les
défendre parce que c'est eux qui
justement cette époque extrêmement
troublé par rapport à plein de sujets
peuvent nous sauver en appliquant la loi
la loi est notre refuge notre remède
donc les juges il faut les défendre il
faut les protéger merci beaucoup Hervé
tes MIM vous l'avez compris ne rater
surtout pas cette formidable série sur
le métier d'avocat mené par Daphné
Roulier à retrouver à la fois déjà sur
le site LCP.fr sur les différentes
plateformes de la chaîne et puis sur la
TNT votre grand entretien ce sera ce
dimanche soir à 23h30 secret défense
chez Gallimard est toujours dans les
bonnes librairies vous restez avec moi
je vous propose d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix ce soir
France Europe Express avec Richard Werly
qui va nous parler de ses activistes du
climat qui pourraient prendre d'assaut
les villes en Europe la question
philosophique de Pierre-Henri tavoyau la
désobéissance civile est-elle un droit
vous nous direz aussi mettre tes mains
et puis vu du perchoir elles dans mon
Agava les commissions d'enquête
parlementaires objets ultra politique
nos affranchis les voici on va commencer
avec vous Richard vous vouliez revenir
en pleine COP 27 sur ces activistes ces
actions coup de poing de défenseur de
jeunes défenseurs du climat il y en a
beaucoup dans les grandes villes
notamment pour dire STOP à l'utilisation
de la voiture au risque de transformer
quoi nos villes en champs de bataille
effectivement Myriam alors champ de
bataille c'est bien le mot qui convient
alors il fait peur mais il correspond à
la réalité d'abord parce que c'est dans
les grandes métropoles il faut le
rappeler que les projets de directives
antipollution ou bien de de comment
dirais-je pour réguler la pollution sont
adoptés par l'Union européenne et c'est
là qu'elles vont avoir le plus d'impact
alors
l'interdiction programmée de la vente de
moteur thermique à partir de 2035 on le
sait on va aussi changer la vie de
beaucoup de gens en termes de mobilité
urbaine et là aussi ça fait peur on voit
la qu'un front comment ça s'ouvrir c'est
celui des actions coup de poing menées
par les activistes soit dans des garages
soit dans des sur des grands axes de
circulation pour dire stop à la voiture
on l'a vu récemment en
[Musique]
urbaine alors les conséquences sur la
vie sociale sur la vie politique sur la
prise de décision sur l'économie sont
beaucoup plus grandes donc oui attention
parce qu'au cœur de nos villes peut-être
demain les barricades écologiques et la
riposte violente qu'elle risque
d'entraîner seront peut-être notre
quotidien dans les prochaines années
merci Richard je vous fais réagir mais
les deux chroniques sont liés ce soir
celles de Pierre-Henri tavoyau du
collège de philosophie va vous
intéresser elle pose la question après
toutes ces actions coup de poing de la
désobéissance civile droit droit droit
légitime ou pas oui le concept est en
fait difficile à définir si on regarde
la Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et
du Citoyen vous avez une petite
contradiction qui apparaît dans
l'article 2 il y a la possibilité de la
résistance à l'oppression mais dans
l'article 7 on se rend coupable si on
résiste à la loi bon voilà donc c'est un
peu ambigu en fait c'est un vieux débat
le débat au 17e siècle entre ceux qui
considèrent que la désobéissance la
résistance est absolument proscrite
c'est par exemple hop ce qui dit certes
il y arrive à que des ordres soient
injustes mais il y a pire qu'un ordre
injuste c'est l'absence d'ordre donc il
faut toujours obéir et ne jamais
résister
attention l'ordre il peut être tellement
injuste qui nous fait replonger dans
l'état de nature et dans ce cas là comme
log disent on a le droit de résister à
l'oppression alors attention la
résistance à l'oppression c'est pas la
même chose que la désobéissance est
absolument importante parce que d'une
certaine façon il y a une grande
différence entre désobéir pour la
démocratie quand on rentre en démocratie
et des obéir en démocratie l'inventeur
du concept de désobéissance civile c'est
David sorrow c'est un philosophe
américain qui en 1846 décide de ne plus
payer ses impôts parce que il veut
protester contre la guerre que les
États-Unis font avec le Mexique et donc
il est emprisonné alors sa tante il est
très déçu parce que ça tente paye sa
caution mais il sort un livre un peu
plus tard la désobéissance civile qui
est un peu la Bible en quelque sorte et
de référence de tous les désobéisseurs
civils la question qui pose ce livre est
très intéressante c'est nous sommes en
démocratie il y a des règles d'endroit
a-t-on le droit de désobéir ou pas
alors votre réponse il faut être clair
non parce que reconnaître un droit de
désobéir au droit c'est juste nier le
droit donc non ça va pas mais ce droit
la désobéissance civile n'est pas un
droit mais c'est une pratique politique
qui peut avoir ses vertus il faut la
concevoir comme ça simplement on
s'engage dans un rapport de force et ce
rapport de force et bien c'est à nos
risques et périls donc il faut en
accepter les conséquences il y a eu des
grands moments dans l'histoire des
démocraties il y a eu la lutte pour les
droits civiques aux États-Unis il y a eu
la lutte contre l'apartheid ce sont des
des obéissances civiles qui ont réussi
qui ont marqué l'histoire et l'histoire
leur a donné raison mais ça révèle la
grande difficulté parce qu'on se dit on
ne peut décider de cette désobéissance
civile de sa légitimité qu’après coup et
le critère est quand même très très
difficile comment on sépare
il faut être clair c'est vrai que d'un
côté on peut avoir les faucheurs des
gens très sympathiques puis l'autre côté
aussi il y a d'autres causes la lutte
contre l'avortement la la la
défense par exemple des des du
créationnisme dans l'enseignement donc
c'est très difficile et sans doute
possible de déterminer mais ce qu'on a
ce à quoi on assiste aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est une banalisation de la
désobéissance civile et ça c'est plus
dangereux parce que la désobéissance
civile ça vaut quand c'est rare ça de la
valeur banalisation ça veut dire qu'il y
a des individus qui s'exonèrent de
toutes les règles de la démocratie elles
sont nombreuses qui ne font pas appel au
recours possible et il y en a beaucoup
médiatique juridique et qui se disent
fort de leur certitude bah je m'exonère
de la vie collective et j'impose ma
volonté ma voix c'est une sorte de droit
de veto personnel
parce que sinon c'est désobéissance
civile devient en fait de la délinquance
inciville merci merci une réaction vous
vous pourriez tient défendre ces
activistes vous l'amoureux des des
grands peintres ceux qui se ce qui
m'aident de de jus de tomate sur sur les
tournesols et je pense qu'il serait
mieux défendu par d'autres que moi parce
que probablement inconsciemment choqué
je trouve pas ça une intelligence folle
pour vous dire la vérité et sur moi ça
n'a pas beaucoup d'efficacité mais je
par contre sur votre sujet je dois me
récuser parce que je suis automobiliste
dans Paris donc je vis déjà un calvaire
quotidien confronté à ce que j'estime
moi être une déovéance civile absolument
illégitime des vélos des trottinettes je
me bats avec Julia minkozy bon je
conduis-moi
je reste automobile électrique oh non
électrique je suis un bon bobo rallié à
la cause mais pas de CO2 c'est bien non
mais je crois que je peux lui plus
qu'une voiture thermique
alors on termine avec vous Elsa ce soir
vous vous voulez revenir sur ses
commissions d'enquête l'opposition les
utilise c'est très fréquent comme des
armes politiques oui chaque groupe
politique ici à l'Assemblée à ce qu'on
appelle un droit de tirage c'est-à-dire
que chaque année et bien il peut
proposer la création d'une commission
d'enquête ça veut dire que pendant six
mois ils vont pouvoir enquêter sur un
thème faire des contrôles sur place et
sur pièce convoquer des personne qui
sont tenues de se présenter qui vont
parler sous serment c'est donc un outil
parlementaire de contrôle et évidemment
encore plus avec cette assemblée
fracturé bien les oppositions sont bien
décidés
à droite les républicains vont enquêter
sur le nucléaire et la souveraineté la
perte de souveraineté énergétique de la
France oui alors que la France craint de
pas pouvoir passer l'hiver faute
d'énergie la droite il y a vu une
opportunité politique on est allé poser
la question au président de la
commission c'est le député du Haut-Rhin
Raphaël chalenberger on lui a demandé
s'il avait pas une petite idée derrière
la tête
le choix de cette commission d'enquête
c'est de dire à quel point la droite
républicaine on est attachée au
fondamentaux dire l'énergie ça devrait
être au coeur du travail de l'État
stratège ça ne l'est plus depuis au
moins 10 ans vous avez un peu écrit les
conclusions à l'avance puisque vous
dites depuis 10 ans les mauvais choix
ont été faits ça veut dire que Nicolas
Sarkozy a fait les bons et puis François
Hollande et Emmanuel Macron derrière ils
ont fait les mauvais moi je pense qu'il
y a eu des faiblesses aussi à l'époque
de Nicolas Sarkozy jamais on aurait dû
céder à certaines sirènes et mettre le
ministère de l'énergie au sein du
ministère de l'Environnement c'est une
erreur mais sur le fond des choix
techniques Nicolas Sarkozy n'a pas
commis d'erreur alors on le rappelle
dans la commission évidemment il y aura
pas que des députés de droite il y aura
des députés tout bord le rapporteur par
exemple ce sera un membre de la majorité
et il entend bien recadrer son collègue
s'il le faut écouter
j'observe avec beaucoup de de plaisir et
de respect que depuis le début de notre
travaux avec le président de la
commission d'enquête on travaille en
bonne intelligence et sans cet esprit
politicien je ne doute pas que ça dure
vous pensez pas quand même que la droite
a cherché à vous pierger un peu avec
cette commission d'enquête mais il ne
faut jamais avoir peur de la vérité par
ailleurs si l'idée ce serait de
d'essayer d'attribuer tous les mots du
monde et en particulier les mots
énergétiques au président de la
République qui n'est je le rappelle par
responsable devant le Parlement ce
serait à la fois mal joué et inopportun
et sachez Myriam qui aura du beau monde
à l'Assemblée Nicolas Sarkozy François
Hollande devrait être auditionné mais à
la fin histoire de bien faire durer la
tension médiatique et politique et les
autres groupes de position alors ils
enquêtes sur quoi alors pour le
rassemblement national la meilleure
défense c'était l'attaque souvent
accusée d'être sous influence russe bah
eux ils ont décidé de proposer une
commission d'enquête sur les ingérences
politiques économiques et financières
des puissances étrangères elle est pas
encore installée c'est pas pas tout à
fait fait puis du côté de la France
insoumise on n'a pas encore décidé mais
on propose de voter pour la création
d'une commission d'enquête c'est un
autre moyen dont dispose les députés en
sans utiliser leur propre droit de
tirage le sujet hubert-files pour
enquêter donc tiens les liens entre la
société uber et un encore très poli de
l'économie ben certains Emmanuel Macron
merci Elsa vous suivez un petit peu les
travaux parlementaires les commissions
d'enquêtes ça vous est arrivé
ma collaboratrice ah c'est vrai mais
comment j'ai pu oublier en tant que je
l'ai oui
très très active très énergique je
l'aime beaucoup on parlait de
transmission quel parcours elle a fait
des progrès phénoménaux depuis qu'elle a
elle a pris la commission de des lois et
franchement je trouve que c'est
formidable
vous êtes le bienvenu ici quand vous
voulez ne manquez pas donc cette série
exceptionnelle col profession avocat la
défense dans la peau c'est ce week-end
sur notre antenne et sur nos réseaux
sociaux merci les affranchis c'est la
posion novembre en fait relâche demain
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
profitez bien
[Musique]